what'd you get on the math part 4 30.
what did you think you needed I don't
know my my teacher told me 420. really
oh my God
I'm so sorry you did it and it's a big
weight lifted off your shoulder it's
been happening all day I'm graduating
the difference that Khan Academy has
made for my students is giving them real
adaptive results that change the
trajectory that that student is on and
they can actually see an outcome as far
as a change in their SAT score we had
students who by using con they were able
to make their graduation requirements
seeing Student Success really is what
propelled us that this is the way we
needed to go in our district the benefit
that Khan Academy brings to our district
here in Osceola County is that it allows
all of our students to have an equal
opportunity to be ready for the SAT we
have proven results with the use of Khan
Academy we know that when students score
as high as they possibly can on the SAT
that it opens doors for them my last
score of sat was 410 and that was like
one question but like behind from
passing the test and now I got a 4 30
and I am able to graduate so I took the
ACT twice um junior year and Senior year
when I took in junior year I use Khan
Academy just yet and in senior year I
took it again I actually was using
Chrono Academy over the summer my points
increased by about 120 130. with
students who have done really well with
Khan Academy are our emerging bilingual
students when they're trying to get this
concordance score on the SAT or act I
see them jump so far since English is
not my first language it actually helped
me how to
read and write for example questions
with semicolons I know how to do them
because of Khan Academy so I think that
was a lot of buy-in as far as from the
student side with using Khan Academy
because they were seeing like oh it's
right or oh it works
foreign
Khan Academy is a guaranteed way to
increase student achievement as it
relates to sat everything I practiced on
con was on the test thank you Khan
Academy you guys for providing the tools
that I needed to pass I really
appreciate it super super happy